في الاثناء دعا رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بين يمين نتنياهو الاسرائيليين الى تحمل
ما قد يحدث في الايام القليله المقبله
وكشف في معرض حديثه عن العمليه
الاسرائيليه انه هو من وجه الجيش واجهزه
المخابرات منذ ثلاثاء الماضي للتحضير لتلك
الاغتيالات التي وصفها بالعاليه والمعقده
والمركبه والضروريه لاحباط مخططات قاده
الحركه وفق تعبيره
نحن في خدم معركه وسنحتاج جميعا في الايام
المقبله الى الصبر والقدره على التحمل قبل
اسبوع عندما اتخذنا قرار الشروع في عمليه
درع وسهم او عزت انا ووزير الدفاع الى
الاجهزه الامنيه بالاستعداد لاي سيناريو
تصعيد وربما في اكثر من ميدان وهذه الليله
اقول لاعدائنا اي تصعيد من جانبكم سيقابل
برد ساحق